what do you do dog
IRS
[Applause]
I said that with pride you
everybody in this room lies to you dog
professional Hall Monitor
ium you see how nervous this black guy
in the head is as soon as he found out
where you worked he hasn't shown his
face since look look look he's still not
showing his face okay dude he can't get
you here don't worry about it how do you
get that good job
what the is that yo
this guy gonna tell me I'll hit money he
won't even pass arithmetics you
made a mistake on my taxi you made a
mistake on my taxes you think the Indian
made a mistake on his taxes 10th grade
Dropout made a mistake on his taxes how
dare you have that job yo be on Floyd
has some respect for yourself